Okay.
I did this a couple months ago and people
liked it, so I'm going to do it again.
I used to do like a weekly book recommendation
and the segments didn't do that well, but
people who like them really did seem to like
them.
So what I'm doing now is every month or two,
I'll just tell you what I've been reading
recently and I'll give you all the recommendations
back to back to back.
So let me give you some nonfiction recommendations.
I recently, uh, red Jared diamond's guns,
germs and steel.
This is a book that has been on my to read
list for a long time.
Finally picked it up.
Absolutely fascinating.
Jared diamond and extraordinarily interesting
guy.
And what guns, germs and steel seeks to answer
is the question of why did peoples from certain
places do better and become the colonizers
rather than the colonizes.
I think that's the right word, uh, than the
colonized.
Maybe to say it another way, um, beyond just
because they had guns and diseases and metal
stuff, right?
Those would be sort of proximate causes.
Yes.
Those who had guns, germs and steel tended
to become the colonizers rather than the colonized.
But the more important question is why did
they end up with guns, germs, and steel before
everybody else.
And the book is fascinating.
It also by, by sort of accident in a way,
debunks a ton of the race.
And Iq nonsense that a lot of alt writers
have been circulating for the last several
years.
Fantastic book.
Absolutely a must read.
I also recently finished up a bad blood by
John Kerry row and bad blood is an extraordinarily
well-written investigative book, uh, by John
Kerry Rupe about the scam that was Theranose
the company, uh, formerly run by Elizabeth
Holmes, who at one point on paper was worth
four and a half billion dollars by virtue
of owning half of Thera no, no.
Which at one point was valued at $9 billion.
Unfortunately, the entire thing was a scam.
And uh, I, I won't say more if you've heard
of the story, you already probably understand
why it's an interesting read if you haven't
get this book.
I read it, I think in three days it was so
compelling.
And then last nonfiction suggestion there
is this a news guy, Dan Harris, who had sort
of like a panic attack breakdown on air several
years ago and he ended up finding meditation
and Mindfulness and sort of rethinking a lot
of elements of his life.
And he wrote a book called 10% happier.
And it's really interesting, not so much because
of the meditation mindfulness stuff, which
I'm already very familiar with, but seeing
it from the perspective of an actual person
who works in the media, I'm also a very quick
read.
I think I read it in like five days.
So those are some nonfiction recommendations.
Fiction.
Okay.
Um, for new stuff.
I recently read banner lists by Carrie von
and I liked it.
It's not my favorite book, but it is interesting
and it is in a sort of, I don't know if postapocalyptic
is the right word.
There has been an incident called the fall
and a humanity has sort of receded, has fallen
back in terms of technology and societal sophistication,
uh, and it's kind of painting a picture of
what the world is like, um, after that fall.
And it's entertaining.
It's not like my favorite book, but it's a
recent book that I really like, uh, enjoyed
reading, although it's probably not unlike
my favorite books list.
I also recently read the murder of Roger Ackroyd
by Agatha Christie.
Previously, the only Agatha Christie book
I had read was a murder on the Orient Express,
which is of course fantastic.
But I wanted to read something else by Agatha
Christie.
So I picked up the murder of Roger Ackroyd.
It's short, it's like a hundred pages and
it's really good in a, in that same Agatha
Christie style.
And then I'm actually rereading John Le Carre's
book, Tinker Tailor soldier spy.
I read it like 10 or 12 years ago.
This is one of John Le Carre's fee, uh, top
books in my opinion.
I'm rereading it.
Um, and I'm getting just as much out of it
and read, read, read, reading it as I did
the first time.
So if you haven't read tinker tailor soldier
spy, please do.
It's fantastic.